and that's what people are finding out
is what what all marriages what they're
rude or about whether they're marriages
of lesbians or gay men or heters
yo yo I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's December 14 2022. we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV
if you have not subscribed click the
subscription button on the platform of
your choice would you do me a solid and
go ahead and do that that cold open uh
was a big moment yesterday of Joe
Biden's mic going out as he was giving
some sort of pre-packaged speech because
they passed the respect for Marriage Act
this was in a very important thing that
the government did uh interracial
marriage it's cool finally gay marriage
lesbians he loves them all he doesn't
care it was just a silly thing that they
passed it doesn't matter nobody doesn't
nobody cares like people have their own
religious beliefs but nobody's stopping
gays and lesbians from marrying although
generally gays and lesbians I guess a
lesbian and a lesbian or a gay and a gay
or a whatever and you know what uh
everybody's getting married but
congratulations if you are in a black
white marriage like the famous black and
white cookie you're good to go now it's
all good uh but it was just sort of
perfect that as Biden is saying the
lesbians are good to go the gains are
good to go tries to say something about
heterosexuals and then the mic cuts out
uh we got a big show for you guys today
we are going to talk
about the Liars because the Liars are
everywhere they're being exposed in real
time they have done an awful lot of
damage we finally have some pushback
against them and the question is I've
brought this up a couple times over the
last few months what do we do about
these people now that it is obvious that
they've lied about everything whether
it's fauci or the CDC or the NIH or the
intelligence agencies or big Tech or
corporate press or any of the Litany of
quote-unquote journalists who have
screwed everything up who have ruined so
many lives and all of that stuff that
now that Elon has Twitter and more and
more people are being exposed to the
truth in real time it's happening in
real time people are tuning out of
mainstream media they're paying more
attention to Alternative Media or
whatever you want to call this kind of
thing and they're waking up and how do
we Arbitrage those two situations a set
of people who have been lied to and
maybe you're waking up although a lot of
them will never wake up versus the
people that that know the truth or at
least something approximate to the truth
how do we look function in a society
together that is the question before we
get to that though I want to give a
healthy shout out to uh to Brock who is
our new team member in studio today for
the first time and it hit me right
before we started the show guys do you
realize in this studio right now we have
a brock
a phoenix and a Connor
and I'm just Dave like you guys all have
three great names those are great names
Brock Phoenix Connor Dave man I'm gonna
do the best I can I mean it's a good
name Dave you know he's the king of
Israel pretty solid name David but I'm
just saying Brock Phoenix Connor it's
cool all right all right we're going to
talk about fauci we got some video from
Tucker and Tulsi gabbard and uh we're
gonna expose some nonsense and all that
good stuff so let's start uh with Tucker
and Tulsi uh Tucker Carlson who if you
listen to the mainstream media is a far
right white nationalist maniac
my own personal opinion would be that
he's a fairly moderate sane person
trying to make some sense of the madness
uh in any event he went on Tulsi
gabbard's podcast Tulsi gabbard course
former Democrat Congressman
congresswoman from well she might be a
man I don't know I think she's a chick
from Hawaii uh who then was the last
person still running against Biden until
the machine just the DNC machine just
got rid of her she has left the Democrat
Party she is now an independent she did
campaign during these midterms with an
awful lot of Republicans it didn't go
that well but she's staking out her
position she is not happy with wokeness
and identity politics and the corporate
collusion with the Democrats all of that
stuff so Tucker went on tulsi's podcast
to talk about all of that and uh they
did not hold back it was very very
revealing from the outset that we have
we have these people in Washington they
don't they don't give a [ __ ] actually
about the American people and it is
about it is about the team sport it is
it about you know those big white boards
on CNN or whatever of like okay we got
this many points for this team that many
points on that team on Election Day say
something like that I mean how could you
as an event Democrat in the Senate
accept a system where the people are not
in charge it is not a democracy
unelected spy agencies are controlling
the outcome of domestic politics like
you're okay with that that's a
dictatorship [ __ ] like what do you
think that is I'm sorry I mean I just
think and I couldn't have less regard
for Chuck Schumer but I know him and
he's not stupid he's not stupid at all
no he's quite smart so he he's never
thought this through he has thought it
through he accepts it as okay and you
know we should never accept something
like that ever first off just Tucker
saying [ __ ] is worth watching just in
and of itself but what's interesting
about that is if you were to go back say
five years ago when Tulsi was a Democrat
she considered herself a progressive
actually if I'm not mistaken when I had
her on the show The First Time In Studio
a couple years back when she was running
for president she was still well she
certainly was describing herself as a
liberal but she I believe was still
saying that she was a progressive she
wasn't that happy with the squad and
what was happening so you could see the
beginnings of tulsi's red pilling but if
you go back say five years ago right so
this is before the last election and
everything the last presidential
election you had Tulsi gabbard who was a
progressive Lefty and you would have
talk Tucker Carlson who certainly is a
conservative and by mainstream accounts
he's somehow far right so you have these
people who five years ago would have
been thought of as Polar Opposites in
the political system and now they're
basically coming together and they're
basically coming together because they
actually believe in Freedom and they
believe in democracy Chrissy and they
want to believe in the institutions that
we have that are supposed to defend
these things and they're upset that a
bunch of unelected bureaucrats and the
swamp whatever you want to call it or
our intelligence services are basically
manipulating us at every possible level
whether it is through big Tech or the
corporate press or anything else so that
is worth noting because strange
alliances are forming and why are they
forming because people are waking up to
the nonsense and speaking of the
nonsense
I want to talk about Anthony fauci Dr
fauci Who has basically lied about
everything and I got a list of things
that he lied about that we're going to
get to in just a moment he went on uh on
it was Chris Matthews show and again
sorry not Chris Matthews Chris Matthews
disgraced MSNBC Guy this is Chris
Wallace disgraced Fox News guy anyway
he's got a new CNN show I guess and
fauci went on there uh and he sort of
doubled down on that I am the science
comment you guys remember that that very
Palpatine I am the Senate I am the
science comment so uh Chris Wallace
asked him about it he kind of backed out
and then he went right back in take a
look
you have also taken some hits about some
comments you made last year here
if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at Tony fauci well people can
recognize there's a person there there's
a face there's a vice you can recognize
you see him on television so it's easy
to criticize but they're really
criticizing science
because I represent science
that's dangerous to me that's more
dangerous than the slings and the arrows
that get thrown at me
your critics accuse you of hubris they
say that you express a certainty and a
disregard
for the views of others can you
understand when you say I represent
science sure I can understand how that
could have been taken out of context and
I probably had to do it all over again
would have changed the wording a little
bit of that what I was trying to say
Chris is that what I was doing was
saying here are the data of why vaccines
are safe and effective so we should be
getting people vaccinated so when you're
criticizing me you're actually
criticizing the scientific facts
it's absolutely staggering this guy is
such a piece of work he should be
studied I'd like to commission a
scientific study to study Anthony fauci
how he can take every position on
everything and still think he's the good
guy it's actually quite remarkable uh
first off when he says that you're
criticizing science which he backed into
again a lot of people weren't
criticizing him they were criticizing
the science a lot of people were going
wait a minute wait a minute you're
telling me if I wear you know a dollar
mask that was made in China that you
know isn't airtight and everything else
and germs are going out this way and
down this way and I can on a plane I can
take it off to eat for a minute but then
I have to put it back up where is the
science in that right that's what people
were asking and when people asked that
question he took that as a criticism of
him if you remember the first year of
covet and I know what they they
purposely make us all crazy so we can't
remember anything if you remember the
first year of Kobe nobody was
criticizing him nobody was people were
welcoming lockdowns we were open to all
of these ideas an awful lot of I can't
say everybody but you know the vast
majority of people also right at the end
there he's still talking about the
efficacy of the vaccines the vaccines do
not work as I said on the show yesterday
it's only my own personal experience but
I think we all have personal experience
that has some validity my entire family
parents sister Aunt Uncle cousin me a
couple other people I know all got
covered last week I'm the only one not
faxed I was completely fine outside
playing basketball all day everybody
else was sick various ages some older
some younger you don't even need to know
that the anecdotal stuff to understand
that we all know now that it was sold
the vaccine was sold to us you will not
get nor transmit covid lie booster shot
you'll get lesser coven lie masks work
lie quarantines work lie it's just lie
after lie after lie but fauci still this
guy I'm commissioning a study that's it
guys we're commissioning these find out
what the f is wrong with Anthony fauci's
study by Dave Rubin and Friends uh he
still cannot believe that people
criticize him it's a bit
bizarre I think in our day and age to
have health officials who are doing
nothing more than trying to get people
to be safe and save their health and
their lives and their family to get
attacked in a way
he was just trying to help everybody
guys he was trying to help you when he
was for locking you down he was trying
to help you when he was for putting your
kids out of school
etc etc which reminded me that
she said a couple weeks ago that he had
nothing to do with school closures you
may remember this they always come back
and say fauci was responsible for
closing schools I had nothing to do I
mean let's get down to the fact
he had nothing to do except we've got
video if we get community-based cases
throughout various parts of the country
then you use that information to make
the decision if they're going to do what
you said which is do this kind of social
distancing that includes teleworking
closing schools Etc by the time we get
to the fall that we will have this under
control enough that it certainly will
not be the way it is now where people
are shutting schools my optimistic side
tells me that we'll be able to renew to
a certain extent but it's going to be
different remember now because this is
not going to disappear so we're going to
have to have in place the capability of
doing the things that we talk about all
the time on this stage to identify to
isolate to contact Trace so if you at
least agree that the general principle
is to try as best as you can to get the
children back to school I think you have
to put that in in the context that an
important issue in that is to make sure
you do whatever you can to safeguard the
safety and the health of the children as
well as the teachers and that should
guide your policy
see as a father if I could just say I
would be delighted to send my kids back
to school I mean remote learning is
horrible especially for younger kids
it's just it's just not the way the kids
are supposed to learn okay we cut a
whole portion of that there are many
many instances of him being for school
lockdowns we also played you guys the
video a week ago remember when people
were asking him about how Draconian the
Chinese lockdowns are that are happening
all over China right now and they've
literally they're literally barricading
people in in giant massive apartment
buildings and they have this zero
coveted policy and related to that he
had the balls the gall to say that yeah
it could kind of work until you get
things under control and it's like you
deserve no respect or power or anything
anymore you bad bad man I'm gonna start
I wrote it down we're going to name this
we're going to start a GoFundMe it's
going to be the national decent person
study of what is wrong with Anthony
fauci brought to you by Dave Rubin and
friends we're going to raise millions of
dollars we're going to study him and you
know one of the things that he did I
think at the NIH was remember he did
that study where he took dogs this is
true he took dogs he put their heads in
like plastic bags basically and then had
maggots eat the dog's faces he did that
in the name of science also Google it
it's actually a real thing anyway what
else has Anthony fauci got wrong even
though if you question him you're
questioning science a guy by the name of
Justin Hart on Twitter had this kind of
kind of fun little list here and let's
see let's just go through it
transmission was Anthony fauci right or
wrong well we know he was wrong because
he said if you get the vaccine you will
not transmit PCR test yes we know he was
wrong fatality rate they got that wrong
many many times over time we knew at the
beginning this was something like 99.9
percent that you'd be okay if you got
coveted lockdowns which he says he's
never four yes he got that wrong school
closures said he was never for it got
that wrong
quarantine the healthy how did that make
any sense it actually made no sense uh
Hospital overload you know it's strange
come back to me for a second and I keep
looking for these videos where are the
videos of the overrun hospitals anywhere
give me a small village that is
unsanitized somewhere in Africa where
you would imagine the entire Place went
down like it was the movie outbreak and
for some reason I have yet to see those
videos maybe I I need a different
computer or something I may not have the
computer power uh plexiglass right we
put plexiglass you go to you go to
Applebee's they put a piece of
plexiglass between you and the fat freak
behind it somehow you're gonna be all
right social distancing just did not
work it does not work masks obviously
we've been through that vaccine efficacy
he got that wrong too so you guys get it
he got all of these things wrong I don't
know you know I said on the show
yesterday I don't know if fauci is evil
and a lot of people were pushing back
like Dave he is evil I I don't know I
don't know I don't know if he is just a
bureaucrat a rich bureaucrat Drunk on
Power maybe that maybe that is the very
definition of evil actually but either
way he should not be listened to yet
people are still putting him on
television and still taking his advice
here's a video from the televised mental
institution of MSNBC with Miko
Brzezinski asking fauci this is
literally yesterday what should people
do because it's the fall and covered and
should everybody get boosted
well certainly the the answer to your
last question because yes everyone
should why can someone explain why did
someone explain why everyone should get
boosted I am not vaxxed I have a healthy
immune system I drank a lot of water
when I had the coven tried to go to
sleep early sweat it out in the in the
sauna
why would I get boosted I didn't get
vaccine the first why should everyone
get boosted why does basic health have
nothing to do with what this man thinks
about as a doctor uh you should maybe
eat less pancakes in the morning and you
should have say I don't know how about
yogurt and fruit
would that be better that would be
better uh you should try to lose a
little weight you should get a little
sunshine why does he never mention any
of these things he only wants you to get
boosted and boosted and he doesn't care
if you're six months old he wants you to
get vaccinated and Over My Dead Body
will my kids be getting mad so he
doesn't care if you're six months old he
doesn't care if you're 12 years old
young and healthy strong immune system
out there in school kids get sick with
things it's actually good for them he
doesn't care if you're 25 and healthy he
doesn't care if you're 70 and obese he
views all of those things as exactly the
same but you're not going to believe
this guys you're not going to believe
this on The View yesterday Whoopi
actually made sense she like the fact
that
that we as regular Americans would be
held accountable really irritates the
hell out of it yeah
just kidding guys I I pumped you there
because that wasn't her talking about
fauci obviously she doesn't want him to
be held accountable that was her
actually talking about Sam Bachman freed
and this FTX thing I apologize for that
we punked them we did an April Fool's
joke why would we do that
uh this is a good one that we found too
check out this timeline of vax vaccine
efficacy and how it was going down as
time went around meaning that at the
beginning it was 100 effective nobody
was going to get covered you weren't
going to transmit it you weren't going
to get covered here is a timeline of
headlines as it just completely dumped
out uh perhaps some of you could if any
of you were friends with Anthony fauci
or family member saying maybe you could
have him watch this oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
highly effective
[Music]
that is good that is good stuff do you
think that might be connected to why
these people want to control the
internet do you think that's why they
want to go out of their way to make sure
that the meme makers are deleted and the
people who go against the narrative are
deleted or why they lie about so many
things so that you can't remember what
happened and that's why I do the show
the way I do it that's why I show you
those videos just watching those numbers
precipitously drop and fauci still
yesterday telling people to get boosted
absolute nonsense but now I'd like to
contrast nonsense with actual sense
common sense and decency which is
happening right here in the State of
Florida yesterday I was one of about
probably about 10 maybe a dozen people
that were invited to Governor desantis's
uh video stream he did a live video
stream yesterday
with a bunch of covet experts a bunch of
doctors a bunch of people who have been
harmed by vaccines it was really quite
extraordinary did a couple hour
basically a live talk show and if you
want to know something about uh DeSantis
that really I think you don't see on the
outside but I can see as someone that's
sort of on the inside of this thing we
go to this big studio and we're going to
show you a couple Clips in just a moment
big Studio you know big giant TV screens
everywhere cameras everywhere as I said
about 10 12 people that were there to to
watch and and report on what was going
on panel of doctors and as I said some
of the people who've been hurt by the
vaccine all of this stuff there's Zoom
people everywhere he's taken all these
questions he did it all live I mean I
watched it happen there was there was no
rehearsal they literally all walked in
and sat down the guy basically ran a
live three-hour talk show uh to bring
vaccine information and now talk about
what Florida is going to do related to
all of the misinformation and vaccine
nonsense here's Governor DeSantis you
know it is against the law to mislead
and to misrepresent particularly when
you're talking about the efficacy of a
drug we see just the other uh just
recently Florida got 3.2 billion through
legal action against those responsible
for the opioid crisis and so it's not
like this is something that's
unprecedented so today I'm announcing a
petition with the Supreme Court of
Florida to impanel a Statewide grand
jury to investigate any and all
wrongdoing in Florida with respect to
covid-19 vaccines did you catch that
that is the chief executive of Florida
the freest state in the world in what
Still Remains to be the freest country
in the world uh saying no more of this
nonsense we are going to look into what
you people did how did you do it who did
you lie to and did that harm Floridians
because if it did we're going to sue the
hell out of you so the man is leading
right now right what do I always talk
about that blueprint for America Rhonda
Sanders is writing the blueprint I think
you could argue to save the world at
this point uh he had a whole bunch of
experts and doctors as I mentioned on
the panel was thrown into everybody live
doing follow-up questions without
looking at notes it was really just a
great uh example I wish you guys could
have seen the behind the scenes portion
of it to really see how on the ball this
guy is one of the experts that he had up
there was ER Dr Joseph Freeman and he
was talking about how he spent most of
his portion talking about how there are
serious adverse effects with these
vaccines at much much higher rates than
other uh vaccines in the past take a
listen scientists Advisory Board votes
against it
CDC goes ah let's not listen to these
guys just recommends it for all age
groups the safe and effective
terminology that's been used has been
based on a
it's just you know it's uncertainty this
is based on it's it's a lie myself along
with uh six other scientists or
international team
we uh
basically went back to the original
clinical trials looked at serious
adverse looking at serious Adverse
Events they're defined by both Pfizer
and modern and assigned by them
we're looking at that which went in to
reanalyze it take a magnifying glass
look closer because they originally
reported that there was no harm there
was no serious harm from these vaccines
and so we basically were using a list
that was a who endorsed list of Adverse
Events that they thought were
potentially caught going to be caused by
the vaccine before
we ever even authorized it to our
surprise
in the Pfizer trial the first first
vaccine to go through it was a 37
increase in the number of serious
Adverse Events that was never reported
not by the FDA not by fives it turns out
when with both Pfizer and moderna we had
a one in 800 risk of serious Adverse
Events of these are from that list so
now to understand what a one in 800
means consider that our other vaccines
have about a one in a million one in a
million maybe two in a Million this is
not the same sort of safe safe and
effective doesn't change it's not even a
scientific wording safe it's not safe
enough it's it's more of a campaign like
a campaign slogan or not even it's a
advertisement and that one in 800 number
that's for short-term risks that's okay
so the guy you heard speaking at the end
talk about the short-term risk that's
Brett Weinstein who's been on the show
many times I I we've sort of lost touch
over the last couple years but I
reconnected with them I'd love to get
him back on he's going to be on this he
doesn't even live in the state of
Florida uh either to Dr Freeman and
either does Dr bhattacharya Who we're
going to talk about in just a sec but
they're all going to be part of this
panel which is absolutely spectacular
the key part of what he said there was
not only I get you guys will understand
the sort of dismissals the CDC just
ignoring a lot of the science but the
numbers this one in 800 so meaning that
in when they were testing the Pfizer and
moderna vaccines the MRNA vaccines they
found out that serious vaccine injury
and further uh we didn't play all of it
but he talked about what Syria serious
means I mean it's real stuff it's not
just like my my fingers tingled for a
day it's like real stuff related to your
heart your brain etc etc your nervous
system one in 800 people were getting
that sort of reaction now you may go
okay well 1800 that doesn't sound like
that much but as he said in normal
vaccines the vaccines that we've all
been taking forever the polio vaccine I
think he mentioned specifically it's one
in a million do you see the difference
between 1 and 800 and one in a million
and fauci's out there every day saying
it's safe and effective which as Dr
Freeman points out safe and effective is
not even a medical term it's not even a
medical term anyway it continues because
as you guys know there has been all of
this information about uh heart disease
with young men specifically myocarditis
uh Dr latipo Who is our Florida Surgeon
General and this guy if he was anywhere
else besides Florida would be a massive
star and I don't want to play the the uh
the sort of woke identity politics game
but it's partly because he is black he
is black now that's not why Governor
DeSantis hired him he hired him because
he's a damn good surgeon and a good
scientist but he is he's ignored
basically by mainstream media because
they can't have a black guy running
around saying that there's a problem
with the vaccine anyway he goes into a
study that he was part of related to
myocarditis we looked at all cause
mortality and and cardiac mortality
after the covid-19 vaccines the study's
preliminary it's not perfect most
studies aren't perfect
but what was there are two things that
were remarkable
the first thing that was remarkable of
course was the major finding which was
there was a signal for a markedly
increased risk of cardiac death in young
men specifically in that age and sex
group so obviously that's that's a huge
finding the second thing that was that
was remarkable is that
scientists many scientists around the
country felt that despite the fact that
young men have already been identified
as a group that is specifically
especially at risk for myocarditis it
was impossible to find that they that
this same group was at increased risk of
cardiac death
the theme is the same you know there's
there's what makes sense and then
there's unfortunately what a lot of our
health officials and unfortunately a lot
of my colleagues a lot of our colleagues
are telling the public
I'm going to give you guys a little bit
of homework today I haven't given
homework on the show in a while I'm
going to give you a little homework your
homework is to find anything that Dr
latapo or Dr Freeman said that is untrue
because I'm seeing them get attacked
left and right all over Twitter
mainstream media corporate press all the
usual nonsense they're gonna ah they're
the science deniers like just all the
usual ad hominem stuff but what's really
interesting about what Dr latipo went on
to talk about is that we're finding all
of this stuff related to myocarditis
with young men and it was at the same
time when young men I mean they're
talking about 12 and 14 year old kids
they're kids say young men they're young
boys uh these this was a group that was
not going to die of covid that actually
has strong immune systems but still
these people like Anthony fauci and the
people at the CDC and the people at
Pfizer and moderna who sponsor all the
mainstream Media news they had no
problem and they didn't mind pushing
that stuff aside sure there's a 37
increase in myocarditis do we care about
that no no guys gotta stock I mean what
do you think doing over here Stanford Dr
Jay bhattacharya who has been on the
show and obviously Brett's been on the
show as well uh he actually moved off
the specifics of sort of what the
vaccines are doing or not doing and he
talked about I would say the more Blue
Sky situation that's going on here
what's what's the bigger issue about
control that seems to be happening all
over the world and by the way this is I
should mention uh Dr bhattacharya was
banned on Twitter even though nobody was
questioning his credentials as a
Stanford professor and scientist he was
banned on Twitter Elon Musk just put him
back he went on to talk about what
perhaps this is really all about this
has been a tremendously difficult time
for uh basically everybody but we're
near the tail end of it and it's time to
start taking stock of what went wrong
and make reforms so this doesn't happen
again I think the centrally important
issue that caused the problems is that
we silenced people
from expressing their thinking
qualified people from expressing their
thinking and as a result the decision
making at the top of the of the of the
country was absolutely abysmal when you
have censorship
the kinds of suppression of voices the
the essentially effectively a social
credit system demeaning people who who
disagree with you know the CDC or or
whatever you're going to get bad
decisions that don't get checked and I
think that's I think we have to we have
to discuss that as well as a a large
number of other pandemic decision
decisions that harmed the lives of
tremendous number of people including
vaccine mandates and many other things
um not not in Florida so much
um uh and I think we owe the American
people that uh and I and I'm looking
forward to to working uh in coming years
to reform American public health so that
when there is another pandemic we do a
much better job than we did this during
this one all right as I said that guy
Stanford Professor scientist does he
seem like an alarmist does he seem like
a far-right maniac does he seem like a
science denier that guy banned from
Twitter until Elon Musk just brought him
back so when you see all these people
freaking out about who's back on Twitter
perhaps they are freaking out because
the truth tellers are back on Twitter
and their narrative is collapsing but
what he talked about there really was I
think the heart of it we silenced people
for a political agenda and why did you
do that because in essence they already
have ushered in this social credit
system this social credit system which
exists in China and on your phone you
have this score and did you tweet about
that did you talk to this person who
were you friends with can you open a
bank account then oh you were at a
trucker protest in Canada oh well it's
going to be a little harder to get a
mortgage Etc et cetera that is the plan
that we are seeing here why did Apple in
the middle of the height of kovid
suddenly put covid tracking on your
phone do you think that that could be
used for something else like the pieces
guys what do I keep saying about that
puzzle we have all the pieces we're
putting it together we don't know
exactly what the cover the Box looked
like so we don't know exactly what we're
putting together but we're getting a
pretty good idea uh here's a little bit
more on uh from the governor uh about
the CDC and uh well do they deserve your
trust and just just show you know that
this is all just a huge political farce
I don't know what is but the reality is
even this in May of June of 2020 uh I
think you've continued to see people uh
in these bureaucracies and in this
establishment behave in ways uh that
have totally squandered any type of
confidence or Goodwill that people would
have and our CDC at this point anything
they put out you just assume at this
point uh that it's not worth the paper
that it's printed on
yeah isn't that effed up too like nobody
wants this it's the exact same thing
that I've said about the mainstream
media for years you guys don't have to
be great just don't be totally horrible
and that's what I think most people
think about the CDC at this point or at
least let's say most woke awake people
not woke people pardon me
um right like the CDC we expect that you
could get some stuff wrong of course you
do and I hate you could get some stuff
wrong our public officials Health
officials everybody could get some stuff
wrong but that you got basically
everything wrong while firing people and
ruining people's lives like no your your
studies and your guidance and
recommendation is not worth the paper
that it's printed on uh but let's go
back to Anthony fauci one more time
because he's very upset that people are
questioning science which of course is
questioning him and why would they be
doing that do you think it could be
because it might be because of social
media you think maybe okay rise of
disinformation
and misinformation
are we developing an anti-science yeah
as well in society the answer is yes the
short answer to your question uh Andrea
but the other thing that's is that
there's so much misinformation that we
we're experiencing the normalization of
untruths where there's so much
disinformation that spread predominantly
through social media
that people just get so used to the
untruth that it becomes normalized which
is really bad because then you don't
push back against it you say well that's
just the way it is
all right I said before that I'm
starting this institute to study Anthony
fauci brought to you by the friends of
Dave Rubin I'd also like to crowdfund a
mirror the world's largest mirror and
have Anthony fauci sit in front of that
mirror
he's telling us that we are all agents
of misinformation while he has been the
prime purveyor of misinformation
I always talk about how when you when
you have a guy like Justin Trudeau who
lies about everything I'm for free
speech while crushing down you know
crashing down on Free Speech you have
people like Gavin Newsom you know I'm
I'm for Choice while he's making sure
that everyone is locked down all of
those things I don't know what that is
about The Human Condition I don't know
what it is I can only describe it as
Solas Solas or or lizard person adjacent
that's what I would have to say I don't
know how else you could operate that
that everything that you say is a lie it
is it is incredible and really why is he
on television talking about that because
what he fears most is what's about to
happen that Elon Musk who now owns
Twitter has all the files all the
internal documents the slack the slack
chats the emails everything related to
who in the government told people to
take things down and once that gets
exposed there is going to be a massive
massive problem because thank the Lord
the Republic have Congress now and they
will most likely fail us and most likely
not enough will happen with any of this
but at least there's a chance and you
gotta have a chance let's continue uh
because uh we do have our rather
spectacular black lesbian press
secretary Karin John Pierre uh and uh
she doesn't like that Elon Musk isn't
Towing the line that Elon Musk dare have
thoughts related to Anthony fauci did
you know um Elon Musk who launched a
series of attacks on Dr Anthony fauci
over the weekend calling for his
prosecution and then he shared some
other memes about him and suggested he
lied about he's lying about the origins
of the coronavirus what's what's your
response uh first of all to specifically
to the attacks on uh Dr fauci so look
we've been very clear about this uh
these attacks these personal attacks
that we have been seeing are dangerous
uh on Dr fauci and other public health
professionals as well uh are they are
disgusting and they are divorced from uh
from reality and we will continue to
call that out and be very clear about
that again these are incredibly
dangerous these personal attacks that we
are seeing lady lady you are dangerous
you are disgusting you are divorced from
reality not Elon Musk who is looking at
the evidence that I think we've laid out
a fairly decent case today to show you
who was lying the entire time and who
actually cares about science so no one
should care what Karin Jean-Pierre says
uh she is a agent of a regime that is
built on lies that's all she is I would
say she is also lizard person adjacent
much like fauci and everything else
they're all in on it together right so
their whole their whole existence is
connected so they can't basically walk
from it because if you walk from it the
machine will turn turn on you it's
basically a giant game of Russian
Roulette and everyone's just waiting to
see who who shoots first who who's
actually going to jump ship first and
say boy it does you know you know what
actually yeah the administration was
coordinating with big Tech and we did
Silence dissent and we did censor people
and everything else but if you want to
see another way the machine launders the
lives one of the things that they do is
if someone dares step out of you know
what's politically acceptable at that
moment they usually will call you far
right or alt-right or something like
that I've been through this over the
years I've often told you about that
Sunday about four years ago when my dad
went to get coffee at the bagel place
that he's been going to for 30 years
that he picks up the New York Times and
there's a front page Sunday article
about how me and Jordan Peterson and
Milton Friedman and Ben Shapiro are the
leaders of the alt-right and my face
giant picture of my face I think on page
three of the New York Times it was a
shock to him he did not know it I had to
admit it after it was the whole thing
anyway one of the things they do is they
lie about your political connections so
this is really interesting so Washington
Post listen to what they wrote about the
Twitter Files The Dump of Twitter files
that have just come out as head of trust
and safety at Twitter Roth this is this
guy yoel Roth
was involved in many of the platform's
decisions about what posts to remove and
what accounts to suspend his
Communications with other Twitter
Twitter officials has been posted in
recent days as part of what must cause
the Twitter files a series of tweets by
conservative journalists Matt taibi and
Barry Weiss okay so this is actually
extraordinary I know it doesn't surprise
you guys but Matt taibi has been a lefty
Progressive his whole life he worked at
The Intercept with Glenn Greenwald I
think he is having a little red pill
moment and kind of coming
to Jesus kind of thing like it is
happening but by no stretch is he a
conservative I certainly don't think the
guys let's say pro-life I have no idea
what he feels about the welfare state or
or immigration or anything but no one in
an honest assessment could call this guy
conservative and Barry Weiss was at the
New York Times her whole life she still
is a liberal uh I think I have no doubt
that she only votes for Democrats as
misguided as that might be and only
surrounds herself really with Democrats
but she's a conservative because she's
going because the the paper The
Washington Post wants to turn Their
audience against these people they want
you to be suspicious of these people
because Elon Musk did not give the
Twitter files to Washington Post he gave
it to them well after enough outrage and
enough tweets about it uh The Washington
Post changed it uh and they removed the
word conservative of course they did not
issue a correction or post that on
Twitter so you get what they do and
again this is exactly why they need to
censor everybody because the Washington
Post wants to be able to lie
about the people who are just delivering
you the information and they don't want
you to be able to call them out for it
but fortunately now that elon's got
Twitter enough people can do it and they
issue well they I suppose it's not
issuing a correction they've removed the
lie but then they don't issue an actual
correction speaking of crazy people
let's go to the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC here is
racist paranoid conspiracy theorists
lunatic Joy Reed who I'm pretty sure is
culturally appropriating or hairstyle
talking about what Elon has done now
that he has Twitter
when musk bought Twitter he promised
advertisers that it would not turn into
a free-for-all hellscape where anything
can be said with no consequences yeah
well
since he took over that's exactly what
it has turned into which while he claims
to have cut the number of times that
users view hate-filled tweets the center
for countering digital hate has found a
notable boost in the number of tweets
that use slurs now as you can see on the
screen
there are four words none of which I can
say on TV even on cable that have jumped
in usage one as much as 200 percent
musk promised that hate speech would be
Max de boosted except according to the
Center for countering digital hate that
has not happened high profile High Reach
tweeters who just so happen to share
conservative political perspectives have
had wide leeway to promote hatred toward
lgbtq plus people in fact some of their
tweets were viewed millions of times
this is the new old normal for Twitter
because the goal apparently is to get
back to the days when Twitter was the
Wild West this woman lives on another
planet and I and
if you're watching her you need help
let's just go through some of this first
off she's uh she's quoting a place
called the center for countering digital
hate I just have no doubt like if
somebody wants to do a little research
on this we'll cover it tomorrow like
definitely a lefty organization and she
okay they're saying these mean words I
can tell you that my experience on
Twitter is completely the reverse since
he's taken over I'm getting more love
more people are there blah blah blah if
there's more happiness there's more
engagement because people are seeing
tweets again now she gives you a list of
scary people these people love lists so
she who does she have on that list it's
a it's a actually a Reuben report
Reunion Show she's got Jack the Soviet
who's been on the show apparently he
hates gays uh you've got uh James
Lindsay uh who wrote a book I think it
was called how to what's it called how
to have difficult conversations I mean
the guy's been trying to make some sense
of things for quite some time uh you've
got Lauren bobert she must hate gays
guys remember when we were in DC a
couple weeks ago and I got out of the
car and she was just standing there what
did she do what did she do big hug big
bear hug from that chick from Colorado
Christina Pusha who works for governor
DeSantis she's coming to my house
tomorrow night for our holiday party
I'll have to ask her if she hates gays
it's all such driverless nonsense and
again it's such an obvious connection
guys I know you can see it I know you
can see it but I want it to be burned
into your retina of how they need
censorship because if they didn't have
censorship then too many people would
know what they're actually doing
on that note I'm going to show you a
black and white video right now and
black and white videos are from a long
time ago this is former FBI agent Howard
Smoot explaining how the government will
use subversion of language to shift
political tolerance towards tyranny uh I
think you will find this is literally
from about 60 years ago maybe 65 years
ago something like that I think you will
find it quite curious and relevant to
the happenings of today a constitutional
republic not a democracy
the ideal of a democracy is universal
equality the ideal of a constitutional
republic is individual liberty
a democracy always degenerates into
dictatorship which promises government
guaranteed equality and security but it
delivers nothing but poverty and serfdom
for the people it robs and rules
America was founded as a constitutional
republic to safeguard the Liberties of
the people against the tyranny of
democracy or of one-man dictatorship
in this Century great strides have been
made toward the goal of subverting our
Republic into a democracy the foremost
tactic of the subverters is subversion
of language
by calling America a democracy until
people thoughtlessly accept and use the
term the totalitarians have obscured the
real meaning of our principles of
government man I need to do a whole show
we're going to do it in the new year a
whole show on the difference between a
democracy and a constitutional republic
but in essence the idea that a
constitutional republic is designed to
protect your individual rights because
that is the buttress against tyranny
right that is the thing that will stop
the authoritarian leaders coming in if
we have equal rights for everybody and
do everything we possibly can to protect
those equal individual rights so we'll
do a whole show on that because I know
it's a little in the weeds
constitutional republic versus democracy
and we think we're a democracy in all of
those things uh all right let's get to a
couple
reubenreport.locals.com comments tallway
says it was hard to trust in the science
once I started to follow the money yeah
I mean like it's so it's so weird
because sometimes it's so obvious like
it so right in front of you that you
think it can't be real we've shown you
that video many times where they show
you all the commercial ins and outs of
all the morning shows and ABC NBC
Nightly News all of that stuff where
it's brought to you by Pfizer brought to
you by moderna brought to you by booster
shots we've shown you that many many
times and it's like man you guys are
reporting on the very people who are
paying to keep the lights on do you
think that is a problem right do you
think that's a problem we have sponsors
on the show we actually didn't read any
sponsor ads today but imagine if I was
reporting on the moink farmers and also
moink was sponsoring the show do you
think there might be a conflict of
interest there you guys they also we all
see it that's the thing that's so
interesting about this uh Florida man
Chuck says I think we need to start a
business where we build fauci pinatas I
bet they would sell like crazy I would
like to hit uh with the baseball bat a
pinata of Anthony fauci I have no doubt
that Media Matters will now clip that
and say that I want to kill him which is
not true I would just like to have a
paper mache version of Anthony fauci
filled with candy that I could smack
around that's it okay there Tony Allegra
says uh whenever someone says follow the
science you should follow the money
ain't it the truth I mean I think you
guys get it
I have to say before we started the show
today one of the things that I do with
the guys is I say how's the show going
to go today and usually you know Phoenix
is kind of bullish on this he'll usually
give me like a 9-2 to a 9-4 uh and
Connor you're you're a little more
skeptical because you've got all the
machines in front of you I'm usually
getting like a high eights with him but
I said to Brock today what do you think
and he said an eight seven an eight like
low eight seven like nothing below a
nine is acceptable here he said an eight
seven on his first day in studio and I
have to say guys nine six
nine six if I do say so myself no lunch
for you on your first day man sorry
guys don't forget to play along
subscribe at rumble.com reubenreport and
if you want to join us for the live chat
during the show which Brock is now in
the live chat every single day and you
can get messages directly to me and
that's where I post all my personal
stuff and pics with the kids and the dog
and life and just all the stuff that I
don't want going on Twitter and
everywhere else reubenreport.locals.com
and uh we didn't mention her all shows
so we leave you
with Kamala Harris godspeed so two
Africa's young leaders I say
I am an optimist about what lies ahead
for Africa and by extension for the
world
because of you
because of your energy
your ambition
and your ability to transform seemingly
intractable problems
into opportunities
simply put
your ability
to see what can be
unburdened by what has been
I think